so yesterday the former prime minister  of japan was shot and killed  so these people are coming into comments  meaning like oh look at that gun control  doesn't work  go [ __ ] yourself  this year alone in the u.s we have had  over 300 mass shootings think about that  for a second you idiots  you guys are [ __ ] wonderful  my gosh whoa there's some anger there  maybe there wouldn't be so many gun  issues in the u.s if like one in four or  five people weren't on psych meds that  might sound controversial but seriously  those things screw you up you're gonna  go to it's called  rxisk.org and look at what psych meds do  to people maybe if a quarter of the  population wasn't on psych meds there  wouldn't be so many mass shootings but i  don't see anybody talking about that